when you're not organized it can slow
you down and here's a really cool way to
stay organized first create a new
project and organize it how you like
with folders for assets compositions and
any other files you might need then go
to file save as file format and choose
Adobe After Effects template project now
let's set up after effects to
automatically load that template every
time you start a new project go to
settings new project tick the new
project loads template checkbox and
choose the project template you just
created and now every time you start a
new After Effects project the template
will automatically load and you're ready
to go with everything you need to stay
organized